[Music]
when I graduated UCLA I moved to
Northern California and I lived in a
little town called Elk on the Mendocino
Coast and I didn't have a phone or TV
but I had us mail and life was good back
then if you could remember it I'd go to
the general store for a cup of coffee
and a brownie and I chipped my film to
San Francisco and lo and behold two days
later it would have been de pon my front
door which was way better than having to
fight the traffic of Hollywood I didn't
have much money but I had time in a
sense of wonder so I started shooting
time-lapse photography it would take me
a month to shoot a four-minute roll of
film because that's all I could afford
I've been shooting time-lapse flowers
continuously non-stop 24 hours a day
seven days a week for over thirty years
and to see them move is a dance I'll
never get tired of their beauty immerses
us with color taste touch it also
provides a third of the food we eat
beauty and seduction is nature's tools
for survival because we protect what we
fall in love with
it opens our hearts and makes us realize
we are a part of nature and we're not
separate from it when we see ourselves
in nature it also connects us to every
one of us because it's clear that it's
all connected in one when people see my
images a lot of times they'll say oh my
god have you ever wondered what that
meant the old means it caught your
attention it makes you present makes you
mindful the mine means it connects with
something deep inside your soul it
creates a gateway for your inner voice
to rise up and be heard and God God is a
personal journey we all want to be on to
be inspired to feel like we're connected
to a universe that celebrates life did
you know that 80% of the information we
receive comes through our eyes and if
you compare light energy to musical
scales it would only be one octave that
the naked eye could see which is right
in the middle and aren't be grateful for
our brains that can you know take this
electrical impulse that comes from light
energy to create images in order for us
to explore our world and aren't we
grateful that we have hearts to can feel
these vibrations in order for us to
allow ourselves to feel the pleasure and
the beauty of nature
nature's beauty is a gift that
cultivates appreciation and gratitude
so I have a gift I want to share with
you today a project I'm working on
called happiness revealed and it'll give
us a glimpse into that perspective from
the point of view of a child and an
elderly man of that world when I watch
TV it's just some shows that you just
better pretend and and when you explore
you get more imagination than you
already had and um when you get more
imagination it makes you want to go deep
or in so you can get more and see
beautiful or things like it could the
path if it's Apothic could leave you
could leave it to a beach or something
and it could be beautiful
[Music]
you think this is just another day in
your life it's not just another day it's
the one day that is given to you today
[Music]
it's given to you it's a gift it's the
only gift that you have right now and
the only appropriate response is
gratefulness if you do nothing else but
to cultivate that response to the great
gift that this unique day is if you
learn to respond as if it were the first
day in your life and the very last day
then you will have spent this day very
well begin by opening your eyes and be
surprised that you have eyes you can
open that incredible array of colors
that is constantly offered to us for
pure enjoyment
look at the sky we so rarely look at the
sky
he's so really north how different it is
from moment to moment miss clouds coming
and going we just think of the weather
the evil of the weather we don't think
of all the many nuances of weather we
just think of good weather and bad
weather this day I'd know was unique
weather may be a kind that will never
exactly that form come again the
formation of clouds in the sky will
never be the same that is right now open
your eyes look at that look at the faces
of people whom we meet each one has a
incredible story behind their face a
story that you could never fully fathom
[Music]
not only their own story but the story
of their ancestors they all go back so
far and in this present moment on this
day are the people who meet all that
life from generations and from so many
places all over the world froze together
and meets you here like life-giving
water if you only open your heart and
drink
[Music]
open your heart - and that incredible
gifts that civilization gives to us you
flip a switch and - electric light you
turn a faucet that's warm water and cold
water and drinkable water it's a gift
that millions and millions in the world
will never experience so these are just
a few of an enormous number of gifts to
which we can open their heart and so I
wish you that you will open your heart
to all these blessings and let them flow
through you
that everyone we will meet on this day
will be blessed by you just by your eyes
by your smile by your touch just by your
presence let the gratefulness overflow
into blessing all about you and then it
will really be a good day
[Music]
[Applause]